This is a a sort of, you have to see it to
believe it.
Video that is extraordinarily weird. This
horrible thing happened where the wife of
an American diplomat named Anne [inaudible]
has been accused of killing a British teenager
in a car accident. The teen was on a motorcycle.
It happened near a British military base that's
used by the U S air force. The parents plan
to start a civil action against the woman
who is driving the car and the woman immediately
left the country after the incident. Now,
as a Diplomat's wife, she is said to have
diplomatic immunity, but there is a question
about that which I'm going to get to a little
bit later. Donald Trump was asked reportedly
on a phone call by a British prime minister,
Boris Johnson, about rejecting and [inaudible]
immunity so that she would have to go back
to the United Kingdom for, uh, a potentially
for a criminal trial. And Donald Trump has
rejected that request. So yesterday he answered
questions in front of reporters yesterday
or the day before.
He was asked about the entire thing and he
says, listen, we've all done it. And the obvious
question is, we've all done what we've all
driven on the wrong side of the road because
we're used to driving in the U S and we were
driving in the UK. We've all run someone over
with a car and then fled the country claiming
diplomatic immunity. Like what is it that
we've all done that Donald is talking about?
He brings up the driving on the other side
of the road is a difficult as they do in the
U K and that these things can happen and that
it's all, it's happened to all of us. Take
a listen to this.
The woman was driving on the wrong side of
the road and, and that can happen. You know,
those are the opposite roads that happens.
I won't say it ever happened to me, but it
did. When you get used to driving on our system
and then you're all of a sudden in the other
system where you're driving, it happens. You
have to be careful. Very careful. So a young
man was killed. The person that was driving
the automobile has diplomatic immunity. We're
going to speak to her very shortly and see
if we can do something where they made it
was an accident. It was an act. It was a terrible
accident.
I won't say it ever happened to me, but it
did. Like what? What is he talking about?
Did it or didn't it? I, I truly, I, I'm, I've
watched this. It must've been 10 times. What
is he saying? And even aside from that, the
great empathizer, right? I mean you just,
Trump has a way of, when there's been a tragedy,
his comments just make you feel much better.
They make you feel much better about the tragedy.
They make you feel much better about humanity.
Yeah. Right now, as far as diplomatic immunity,
I alluded to this earlier, there is a question
about the diplomatic immunity that is being
asserted. International lawyer, Mark Stevens
is claiming that actually an [inaudible] did
not have diplomatic immunity in the U K because
her husband, Jonathan [inaudible] was not
actually on the official diplomatic list.
And that by extension, his wife Anne is also
not protected by diplomatic immunity.
It's always a mess. I have no idea what will
ultimately come of this. It's of course a
horrible tragedy and Trump saying we've all
done it is about as brutally glib as a response
to what is effectively vehicular manslaughter.
So my questions to you are, what the hell
is Trump talking about when Trump says we've
all done it? What is he saying that we've
all done when Trump says, I won't say it ever
happened to me, but it did. What is he saying
happened to him? Let me know what you think.
Uh, post a reply. If you're watching on YouTube,
send me a tweet. If you're on Twitter at D
Pacman, we will take a quick break and be
back right after this. I want to talk about
the Ellen George W. Bush thing. I want to
talk about Rudy Giuliani going cuckoo for
cocoa puffs during a Fox business interview
with Trish Regan and I also have unfortunately
a really kind of depressing
voicemail to respond to today, but that may
be, will, will let us discuss an interesting
thing, all of that and more coming up right
after this short break